what do you think ariana brings as a
coach to the voice
well the obvious is her voice
that's the voice coaches geeking out
over first time coach ariana grande i'm
grateful
kelly clarkson blake shelton john legend
and host carson daly sat down with the
mega superstar on the today show and
let's just say everyone is a total
orientator i can sing along to pretty
much any song of hers i'm a super fan
i'm going to be real y'all she's funny
on camera but like a hundred times
funnier behind the scenes even blake
who's notorious for being a competitive
coach is getting along with the thank
you next singer what was your opinion of
blake before working with him on the
voice and what is it now i thought he
was lovely and i still think he's just
as as lovely
you guys sit next to each other yes and
as we're doing the show i'll see you
every now and again sort of cheersing
each other that's when they're making
fun of me
our bond has been that we both make fun
of kelly
all jokes aside kelly told dt she's been
a fan since before ari joined the show
kelly what are your thoughts with ariana
grande joining my thoughts are this is
my last chance to win the voice
no i'm a huge fan of her voice i love
her voice i've only run into her a
couple times and she's so sweet like
every time we run into each other so i'm
just a fan i i would love like as a
person that's competed in a show like
this i would love to be able to pick a
you know someone like her she sings so
beautifully and is um just killing it
still in the charts like she's just an
amazing coach like to have on the show
so i think it's going to be really cool
and fun and i like female energy so but
the coaches are not the only ones
fangirling over the 28 year old singer
the contestants are too what else do you
like to sing ariana grande i am a huge
ariana grande fan the biggest fan
obsessed with you oh my gosh she even
came with a ponytail
the season 21 trailer recently dropped
and it's obvious everyone including the
crowd are ari stans is everybody in here
just obsessed with ariana you have no
chance push it back push it back
[Applause]
it's the most fun i've ever had in my
whole life and the superstar already has
her own personalized red button i would
love to work with you it would be so fun
it would be an honor thrilled by your
performance pick team legend
but friendly competition aside the
coaches are stoked to have ariana join
the voice
knowing what kind of audience she brings
to the show knowing how much people love
her out in the world it's going to be so
great for the voice she's got this
incredible talent with her not just her
tone but her range
and then also like experience she's been
doing it forever since she was a kid
like that's that's an amazing
amount of experience to be able to
bestow upon your
your artist that you're working with